i'm so happy that the  the ceiling has gotten broken through of  there only being one  it female rapper at a time because that  shit's over with now yeah  i mean i think it's been over with but  just now you have the industry  accepting it because it's a different  thing when there's always been girls  rapping of course there's always been  girls that were fired you know  and they just didn't get their due  because  you know the way it was set up so it's  like now that i think like as one girl  starts to go then another girl goes and  another girl goes  it's making people open their eyes and  making labels wake up and be like hey  listen  we festivals everything we have to start  pouring into the girls a little bit more  because  there's something going on here and the  people are picking it like  you know what i'm saying the people are  the ones that consumers are are speaking  through yeah 100